В цій амбулаторії в одному зі спальних районів Києва - прийомні години,
але звичних черг немає.
Це лише один з видимих результаті медреформи,  що стартувала майже два роки тому.
Пацієнти отримали можливість обирати собі сімейного лікара.
Такого наприклад, як Вікторія Загірова.
Вона підтримує нинішні реформи МОЗу, зокрема, й Уляну Супрун.
З позитивної сторони вона змогла щось поміняти.
Тому що вже давно нічого не змінювалось,
Я так відмічаю,  що реформа була, але нічого не змінювалось.
Сімейні лікарі були, але вони приймали як терпевти.
Педіатри - як педіатри. Зараз реально сімейні працюють як сімейні.
Залежно від навантаження лікарі в цій державній амбулаторії
отримують від 11 до 16 тисяч гривень:
удвічі більше ніж в дореформівські часи.
хоча деякі інші комунальні медзаклади перенесли або закрили,
цей, як і всі, що підписали угоду за Національною службою здоров'я,
- отримав фінансову незалежність.
Від чого залежить критика?
Тому що  суть реформи - самостійність.
Лікар на своєму рівні має приймати рішення,
якщо раніше лікарі звикли, що роблять все по вказівці керівництва,
хтось чекає, що буде вказівка, що треба щось робити,
а хтось встає і робить роботу.
Етапність медичної реформи прописана в законодавстві України,
її поступ не залежить від зміни міністра.
Втім не на камеру сімейні лікарі кажуть, що бояться
згортання і блокування реформи, як це не раз траплялося в Україні зі зміною влади.
Підживлює сумніви й те, що у Верховній Раді партія "Слуга народу"
має монобільшість та може одноосібно змінювати законодавство.
А Володимир Зеленський ще під час передвиборчих дебатів на стадіоні
слів про медреформу не добирав.
Яка це нафіг реформа!
Критикують реформу так само голосно, як і вихваляють.
Вихваляють - за рішучість все ж таки реформувати застарілу
і наскрізь корумповану ще радянську систему охорони здоров’я.
А також за західні стандарти підзвітності,
розорості фінансування та ставлення до паціентів.
Критикують - теж за рішучість, але у знищенні старого -
від сільських поліклінік до схем держзакупівель ліків.
А ще - за небажання прислухатися до критики та нарікань невдоволених.
Одним з найгучніших опонентів Уляни Супрун останніх місяців
став радник президента Зеленського Михайло Радуцький,
засновник та колишній співвласник приватної клініки "Борис".
Спікер "Слуги народу" з медичної тематики каже:
пані Супрун навряд залишиться на чолі міністерства,
але про відкат реформ і мови немає.
Ми точно не будемо зупиняти трансформацію системи охорони здоров’я.
Ми не ідіоти. Це перше.
По-друге, Ми не будемо ламати те, що вже зроблено і воно працює.
Те, що не зроблене і працює не зовсім вірно.. Ми зробимо аудит
і відкорегуємо деякі речі.
Одна з речей, які хоче відкорегувати команді Зеленського -
модель соціального медичного страхування.
МОЗ запроваджує її за прикладом країн Британської співдружності,
які медицину оплачують з податку на додану вартість.
Радуцький пропонує німецький підхід,
за яким охорона здоров'я фінансується з окремого податку -
7.5 % зарплатні сплачуєте ви
і ще скільки ж до вашої страховки додає роботодавець.
В Національній службі здоров'я - новоствореному органі,
що нині є єдиним замовником та платником медичних послуг,
вважають: німецький досвід Україні не підійде, оскільки
значна частина економіки в тіні.
Чи зміниться робота НСЗУ з новим урядом
і новим баченням медичної реформи, тут не коментують.
Звітують лише про те, що українці медреформу підтримують,
адже 27 мільйонів пацієнтів вже підписали декларації з сімейними лікарями.
Да, підписувала, Поки все добре, нас все влаштовує.
Педіатр відповідає на питання, на вайбер -
так набагато краще, мобільніше.
Не підписувала. А чому? Я просто про це не чула.
Ми заключили декларацію, я, дружина,
а дітей з дитячим лікарем, якого він знає з року.
- Зручніше стало?
- Зручніше, але як сказати.....
важко стало попасти на прийом до лікаря, коли ти дійсно за хворів.
Поки новий уряд Володимира Зеленського не оголосить програму дій –
страх про згортання медреформи нікуди не зникне.
Тим більше, що йдеться про одну з небагатьох реформ останніх п’яти років,
яка була запущена та не забуксувала і не була згорнута через труднощі й опір старої системи.
Водночас поки відбувся лише перший етап трансформації української системи здоров'я.
Попереду - реформа вторинної та третинної ланок:
тобто спеціалізованої та високоспеціалізованої медичної допомоги,
а зокрема складної діагностики, операцій, трансплантології тощо.
І за цей, значно серйозніший етап тепер беруться відповідати
вже Володимир Зеленський та "слуги народу".